les états unis vendre des armes à taiwan
ce n'est pas un scoop ce qui est plus
surprenant en revanche c'est le rythme
adopté par washington pour ses marchés
avec taipei
jusqu'à présent les exportations étaient
espacées dans le temps pour ne pas trop
froisser pékin
mais cette fois ci ce sont sept systèmes
d'armes qui devraient être achetés
simultanément par taïwan selon des
sources proches des discussions est cité
par plusieurs agences de presse les
marchés concernent des missiles de
croisière des drones ou encore des mines
en clair des armes destinées à ce que
taiwan se défendent d'une supposée
incursions et demi sur son territoire et
quand on parle d' ennemi on comprend
clairement qu'il s'agit de la chine
l' empire du milieu considère taïwan
comme un territoire chinois
il faut dire aussi que les liens
économiques sont très forts entre taipei
et pékin que les états unis vendre des
armes à taiwan dans un contexte de
relations au plus bas avec la chine
c'est clairement vécu comme une nouvelle
provocation par les autorités chinoises
surtout que cette vente s'accompagne
d'une visite inédite
comme annoncé par un communiqué cette
semaine le sous secrétaire d'état
américain en charge de l'énergie de la
croissance économique et de
l'environnement est en visite à taïwan
un déplacement très rare pour un
officiel de ce rang et qui déplaît
fortement à pékin par le fui les états
unis ont délibérément organisé la visite
du sous-secrétaire d'état à taïwan ce
qui constitue une grave violation du
principe d'une seule chine et va à
l'encontre des trois communiqués
conjoints etats unis chine
cela encourage l'attitude arrogante des
forces séparatistes indépendantistes de
taiwan et nuit aux relations etats unis
chine ainsi qu'à la paix et à la
stabilité du détroit de taiwan la chine
s'y oppose fermement et a déjà fait de
sérieuses observations aux états unis en
août déjà le ministre américain de la
santé s'était rendu sur place provoquant
là encore la colère de la diplomatie
chinoise
on notera également que cette semaine à
new york la représentante américaine aux
nations unies a dîné avec un responsable
taïwanais ne cachant pas ses intentions
à savoir se dresser face à pékin et
promouvoir l'émancipation de taïwan
tout cela se déroule dans un contexte
très particulier pékin washington
s'opposent sur deux
nombreux dossiers accusations
d'espionnage guerre commerciale ou
encore gestion de la pandémie
et si les états unis intensifient leurs
pressions sur la chine
c'est aussi parce que trump en a fait un
argument de campagne
pour preuve cette publicité réalisée par
l'équipe de donald trump est dévoilée
par le site dit il intitulé sibide on
gagne la chine gagne une vidéo qui met
en parallèle des propos de joe biden
plutôt conciliant avec pékin et la
courbe des emplois perdus sur le sol
américain
[Musique]
ce clip de campagne illustre à merveille
à quel point la thématique des relations
sino américaines s'est invitée dans
l'élection présidentielle trump accuse
ben hayden de faiblesse face à la chine
et ce dernier rétorque en pointant du
doigt l'échec de l'accord commercial
signé par trump avec pékin à moins de 50
jours du scrutin la campagne américaine
se joue donc aussi à plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres de washington